[Music]  it's funny Robert great to have you here  we were talking about this last time it  was such an iconic performance in  Terminator 2 that when I see you  casually walk out from behind a curtain  like this it's not what I'm expecting is  this  yeah that's how you need to come out of  a curtain precision running right yeah  precision you should start coming out  from behind the curtain Andy and I  should start backing away all around the  audience that did they teach you how to  move Iran we did the we did the run came  from the martial arts training that we  were doing from out of the movie and  they wanted me to create something that  looked real efficient and you know  streamlined and yeah just sort of  evolved into what you saw right there  that's why I didn't get that part I'm  gonna audition my running was like oh  [Laughter]  wait that wouldn't work oh wow I  wouldn't get a target select  you